good evening, according to the Kyiv authorities, either argue or that they began to conduct an active counter-offensive operation, well, let's see how it will be, how it will end, the general staff, campaigns during the operation, makes operational decisions, something is considered a key main goal, the main goal is to liberate the entire territory of Donbass this work continues despite these attempts to counter-offensive by the Ukrainian army, we have offensive operations in the Donbas itself, sometimes they stop, they go on, go on at a slow, slow pace, but gradually, gradually, with the bones, the Russian army occupies new and new territories, I pay attention, but we are fighting an incomplete army, we cook only part of the Russian army, only contract parts, but naturally this is connected with certain parameters of the personnel, and then therefore we are not in a hurry in this part, but by and large, in essence, there are no changes at the entrance and of course we see these attempts to conduct
carrying out some
terrorist acts in an attempt
to damage our civilian
infrastructure, we really
respond to this quite restrained, but
for the time being, quite recently, the Russian
armed forces delivered a couple
of sensitive strikes there, but how will we
consider that these are warning strikes
if the situation develops further
in a similar way, the answer will be more
serious, I don’t know if there was any public
information on this subject, even
attempts to carry out terrorist attacks, if not on
the objects themselves, then around our
nuclear facilities, the author’s nuclear power plant
on the territory of the Russian Federation, I’m
not talking about the Zaporozhye super station
we see it all, we control it, of course, we
will do everything to prevent a
negative development of events and the
answer will be if they don’t
understand in the end that
such methods are not allowed, they are essentially
no different from the methods of terrorism,
I know your position on the conflict in
Ukraine is
concerned about you  the things that you constantly
say, we will do everything to ensure that,
believe me, everything stopped as quickly as
possible, unfortunately, only the
opposite side, the leadership of
Ukraine, declares
that it has abandoned the negotiation
process with it that it wants to achieve
its goals by
military means as they burn on the
battlefield  you